This video is brought to you by innovative language,
the creators of Indonesian pod one Oh one and Filipino pod one Oh one,
click the link in the description to check out their huge collection of audio
and video lessons for students of all levels. Hello, everyone.
Welcome to the Lang focus channel. And my name is Paul. Today.
We're going to compare to Gallog, otherwise known as Filipino,
the lingua franca of the Philippines and Indonesia,
the lingua franca of Indonesia,
the most widely spoken variety of Molay basically everything I say about
Indonesian.
And this video will also apply to Molay because their standard forms are very
close to each other, aside from some different vocabulary.
But since I'm more familiar with Indonesian, the samples in this video,
we'll focus on Indonesia to Tagalog on the one hand and Indonesian and other
forms of Molay on the other are not mutually intelligible,
but native speakers of either language often say that they feel they should be
able to understand the other language, but they can't.
This is probably due to their similar pronunciation and intonation,
and they might also hear some similar words in the other language,
partly because of the common origins of the two languages Molay including
Indonesian,
since they're essentially the same language and to get log are both members of
the Maliah Polynesian branch of the Austronesian language family.
That means they developed from the same language proton Maliah Polynesian,
from which all members of that branch descendant speakers of proteome Maliah
Polynesian first migrated from Taiwan to Northern Luzon in the Philippines
before spreading out across much of maritime Southeast Asia and the Pacific,
most of the languages of Philippines and most of the languages of Malaysia and
Indonesia outside of Papa, that is also descended from proton Maliah Polynesian.
So at their core Malaya and Tagalog are related though.
They've been diverging from each other for at least 4,000 years,
and maybe much longer during that time they have developed their own features
and have undergone different influences influences on Malai Sanskrit had a
heavy influence on Malaysia vocabulary and literature beginning in the seventh
century, followed by Arabic in the 14th century.
Once Islam was established in the archipelago later on Molay was
influenced by English in British colonial territories and Dutch in the Dutch
colonial territories, modern Indonesian,
which began to be called Indonesian only in 1928,
contains more Dutch influence while Malaysia in Malaysia,
Brunei in Singapore contains more English influence influences on Tagalog.
One of the major influences on tagalo was actually Molay,
which served as a lingua franca throughout maritime,
Southeast Asia for centuries.
So some of the similarities between Malaya and tagalo STEM from their ancient
common origin and some of their similarities STEM from the more recent influence
of Malayan on Tagalog,
then the Spanish arrived in Philippines in 1521 and left a massive footprint
on to Gallo and other Filipino languages.
What percentage up to Gallog words come from Spanish estimates range from 20%
to 33%.
This definitely accounts for a lot of the difference in vocabulary between
tagalo log and Malayan. Indonesia,
Philippines also became a colony of the United States for several decades,
beginning in 1898. And as a result,
English as the second official language of Philippines and takeout log has many
borrowings from English. Since I'm focusing on Indonesian for the samples,
I'm simply going to refer to it as Indonesian from now on rather than saying
Indonesia and Malaysia all the time. Generally speaking,
Indonesian and Tagalog are fairly different in terms of grammar and sentence
structure, in terms of pronunciation, they're quite similar.
Stop consonants in both Indonesian and the gal log are [inaudible] meaning that
there's no puff of air after the continent.
The way they are often is after to and cook in English.
They both also lack Viva and fo sounds except for a small number of lone words,
but many speakers will pronounce them as BA and BA.
They also have similar sets of vowels to Kellogg has five, ah,
a E O oo, and Indonesia has five vowel letters.
But with six sounds, because E is pronounced two ways,
either as or as a Schwab in terms of vocabulary,
the majority of words are different, but there are also many similar words,
including many common basic core words. For example,
some personal pronouns and family vocabulary are similar. The words for it.
You singular go eco
we Comey Tami, Kita, Kita.
Indonesian. This is we including the listener and it to get log.
This means me to you or we in the duel UN meet together.
Child are not male.
Lucky, lucky, lucky, lucky.
There are also numerous words related to household and everyday life.
Mongo Mongkok mosquito net Colombo.
You'll notice that oftentimes where there's an oo sound in one language,
there will be an old sound in the other door.
Into, into one table. Major NASA.
Kellogg word is a Spanish loan. And they also say, Vanessa,
the Indonesian and Malai word is also a loan from Portuguese Meza
ladle.
And sun dock.
And in Malaysia and Indonesia, this also means spoon, nature, words,
rock or stone.
But to wind onion,
honey sky Lang Lang fire RP
a boy.
Well notice that E at the end of a word in Malaysia and Indonesian sometimes
corresponds to oil and Tagalog pig. Bobby Bob boy,
crocodile.
Buddha Bleier.
Numbers and units of time, moon or month Boulin one.
Week Mingo lingo.
That's a Kellogg where it comes from the Malai word.
And the Molay word is from Portuguese.
Domingo year. Uh, Hoon that one four, um,
but APPA five Lima, Lima, six numb,
I mean thousand reboot lipo parts of the body.
I Marta face Mooka
brain tap,
basic States and emotions. Hope ASA, ASA,
sick or sickness. It's not cute. Suck it delicious.
So depth set up in tagalo.
This is the most common word you see in advertisements and so on in Indonesian
enact. Yeah.
It's more common to be afraid,
doc taco to laugh Tala
Salama safety Salama.
Log it's basic. Meaning is thank you. Whereas in Malayan, Indonesian,
it's often used in greetings like Salama buggy, meaning good morning,
other basic verbs.
Berta bossa enter muscle Paso.
It's worth pointing out that ma and PA are both bilabial sounds.
They are both articulated with your lips together.
So it would be easy for one sound to gradually change into the other.
To drink me noon, to open.
Boca Boca, to help all along.
Of course, I've been intentionally pointing out words that are similar,
but I want to be clear that most words are not the Sam.
So let's look at some sentences in either language so that we can compare their
sentence structures,
but we can also see a more representative sample of their vocabulary.
In general. These sentences mean my child likes cats first and Indonesian
word for word it's child, my like cats and into God.
[Inaudible].
For word it's like focus, marker child.
My two pleural marker cat. One part here seems similar.
I'm not [inaudible].
But we could change this word here. Bussa to poutine, which means kitten.
Then the sentences would be even more similar.
We can see that Indonesian is basically SVO at its core.
S V O to Kellogg is basically V S O but another way
to think of it is as predicate subject,
because it's not always a verb in this position. In fact, this word here,
mahi league is not actually a verb. It's an adjective meaning fond of,
but a verb would appear here in the same position. Basically,
these two pieces of the sentence are reversed in Indonesian and to Kellogg,
that's the more common than natural word order into catalog,
but there's also an inverted word order. That's more similar to Indonesian,
but is generally considered less natural and is used less often.
[Inaudible] the subject here on a call.
At the beginning, followed by the inversion marker. I followed by the predicate.
This is less common and more formal,
but probably more intuitive for an Indonesian speaker and for English speakers
as well. Notice that the tequila sentence has this word,
that the Indonesian sentence doesn't have on a focus marker.
This comes before the focus of the sentence,
whether it's the subject or the object.
Another thing the Indonesian sentence doesn't have is a plural marker like manga
in Indonesian, the plural can be shown with reduplicate like witching coaching,
but it's not always used. Of course, Indonesian also lacks an inversion marker,
like the word I, and to Kellogg in general to get log features,
more little function, words and particles than Indonesian does,
especially standard Indonesian colloquial.
Indonesian has some more little words like that. Verbs.
One difference between Indonesian and tagalo verbs is that an Indonesian,
they have no conjugations for tents or aspect while to gala verbs are
conjugated for aspect though.
Neither language has different conjugations for person and number.
Let's look at a quick example with Indonesian muscle and Tagalog Pesach,
meaning enter these sentences mean he entered the school in Indonesian
Nicola and into Gelug.
[Inaudible].
In the tequila verb. There's an infect, which is used for completed actions,
but there's nothing like that in the Indonesian verb.
If we want to talk about an action that's happening now,
like he's entering the school. It's like this in Indonesian
[inaudible] and integrate.
Well, my [inaudible].
If we want to talk about an action that hasn't happened yet,
like he will enter the school. It's like this in Indonesia.
[Inaudible] and then together.
[Inaudible].
Notice that in Indonesian, the verb itself doesn't change,
but rather an aspect marker comes before the verb and it may be left out.
If the context makes it clear already into Kellogg,
the verb itself is inflected differently.
You may also notice that some of the Tagalog inflections are in fixes in the
first case. And in the second case,
there's a doubling of the first syllable followed by the,
in fixing of Indonesian verbs do not have in fixes.
There are numerous prefixes and suffixes,
which changed the meaning of the verb in different ways. For example,
by making it transitive or causative or passive,
but there's nothing for tents or aspect,
actor focus and patient focus into Kellogg verbs are either actor focus or
patient focus.
That means they have different conjugations depending on whether the focus of
the sentence is on the doer of the action or the receiver of the action.
For example, the student read a second.
[Inaudible].
This is actor focus. So the focus is on the student, the doer of the action.
A student read the science book. This is patient focus.
So the focus is on libral the receiver of the action.
You can see that the verb inflections that are in fixed to the root are
different for actor focus and patient focus.
You can also see that there are two words that are switched in either sentence.
Um, and none on is the InFocus marker. And none is the out of focus.
Marker. As a quick side note,
I should point out that the noun with the InFocus marker on is often interpreted
as definite.
Whereas the noun with the out-of-focus marker is often interpreted as
indefinite,
but definiteness can be changed by adding additional words like [inaudible]
meaning one.
And it can also be understood from context based on what has been previously
mentioned.
Indonesian doesn't exactly have active focus and patient focus like tagalo does
it does have something similar, but simpler,
a distinction between subject focus and object focus.
Subject focus is the basic type of sentence. Like this sentence,
meaning a student read a science.
[Inaudible].
Technically Indonesian has no definite or indefinite articles.
So the announced here could also be considered definite,
but we could more explicitly express definiteness by adding Nia,
which means it's either now or to both.
[Inaudible] yeah.
Or you could use the demonstrative pronoun.
It meaning that object focus usually places.
The object first.
[Inaudible].
Science book was read by the student. Alternatively, this could be.
Book is what the student read. Notice that in Indonesian,
there are no markers that show focus or lack of focus like there are.
And to Gallog,
we usually know whether it's subject focus or object focus based on which one
comes first in an object focused sentence in the third person,
the prefix deep attaches to the verb, but in the first and second person,
any prefixes dropped from the.
[Inaudible].
Dan's book is what I read.
Notice that the verb Bacha doesn't have its usual prefix mum,
because the sentence is object focus and it doesn't have the prefixed D because
that's only for third person into Kellogg.
All the personal pronouns are different depending on whether they are in focus
or out of focus.
The out-of-focus ones are actually genitive pronouns because they're also used
as possessives in Indonesian. Most personal pronouns are the same,
regardless of whether they are the focus of the sentence or not,
as you can probably see tagalo on the one hand and Indonesian and Malai on the
other clearly have some similar features that show that they are related such as
they're similar pronunciation and similar core basic vocabulary.
But it's also obvious that they have diverged so much that they are not mutually
intelligible with each other,
partly because of their different sentence structure.
And partly because of their largely different vocabulary.
It's worth remembering that together log is just one language of the Philippines
and that there are many languages spoken in Indonesia and Malaysia speaking
countries like Malaysia and Brunei as well to Kellogg and Malayan Indonesian are
not necessarily the two most similar languages from those countries.
The question of the day for speakers up to Gallagher and Malayan Indonesian.
How well do you understand speakers of the other language?
Do you understand anything?
Do you recognize some words when you hear the other language?
Let us know in the comments down below,
if you're interested in learning Indonesian or Filipino,
I recommend you click the link in the description to check out Indonesian pod
one Oh one or Filipino pod one Oh one.
They have hundreds of audio and video lessons with full transcripts for students
of all levels, sign up for a free account and give it a try and a special,
thanks goes out to my Patreon supporters,
especially these ones right here on the screen.
They are my top tier Patrion supporters. And that's why they're in the video.
So many special thanks to them and to everyone.
Thank you for watching and have a nice day.